The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So the first
thing we're going to do,
is a power module.
And it's important
that when you're
trying to get draw
power from any source,
even a battery or anything
like that, you want
to draw the maximum
amount of power,
you need to have the
right load on it.
So we're going to try to
figure out, experimentally,
what the right load is
for this solar panel.
And the way you do that, is you
up a resistor or potentiometer
in a closed circuit around this.
First, you measure
the resistance of it.
Then you hook this up
in a closed circuit
and measure the
voltage drop across it.
And you can calculate power
from v squared over r.
And so you just do that for a
bunch of different resistances,
just changing this.
And you should be able to get
a graph that goes up and then
down if you graph power
versus resistance.
And based off of that,
you can figure out
what the appropriate
load to place on it is.
And so we'll generate
a power curve for that.
Again, make sure you don't
measure the resistance when
it's hooked up because you're
going to fry the voltmeter.
And then the second thing
we're going to have to do,
is optimize the angle.
So you want to put the solar
panel at different angles,
both in this direction
and in this direction,
and measure, for a
variety of angles,
what the power output it is.
And so for that, you can
just choose a resistance
with the potentiometer
and then measure voltage
and get power that way.
And then I have
protractors somewhere.
Yeah, or what?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Close enough, yeah.
And so you can use
that to measure
the angle of the solar panel.
And when you're doing
this, I want you to take,
for the angle ones
and the shading ones,
I want you to take at
least 10 data points.
And for the voltage
one, I want you
to take at least 15 data points
for different resistances
and powers.
And then the last thing
we're going to look at,
is how shading the solar
panel affects the energy being
outputted by it.
In this case, I want you to--
if you look at
these solar panels,
each of these long things
is an individual cell,
and they're wired in series.
So I want you to shade the
solar panel going down this way,
and then going across
this way, and just
measure the surface area
of the exposed solar panel.
And then, for that one, just
choose the angle that you like,
and choose a resistance
that you like,
and then measure power
being outputted by that.
As you can see, it's kind
of annoying to attach wires
to other wires in
the developing world,
especially if you don't
have soldering techniques
or anything like that,
easily available.
So there are a lot
of different ways
of attaching them together.
A lot of times, the way
you'll see people wire things,
is just taking two wires
and twisting them together.
And it works, as a
short-term solution,
but you'll see entire
systems rigged up that way,
and yeah, it's not
particularly good.
To-- are you all comfortable
calculating power given this?
Where you just do
v squared over r?
AUDIENCE: 19.5.
PROFESSOR: We're not going.
Yeah, we're not
going to use this.
AUDIENCE: Goes to
500. so go up to 20.
go up by.
20.
Yeah, it's gone up to 20 now.
PROFESSOR: Base solar
panel outputs 50 watts,
and most of the tiny
resistors you see
are rated for a quarter
watt or a half watt.
So if you hook them up to
this, they would just burn out.
They get super hot and burn out.
So this one's rated for, I
think like 0.3 or 0.4 amps.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: So change your
angle relative to pointing
to the sun.
Did that make sense?
AUDIENCE: You mean
like, yeah, so--
PROFESSOR: So if
the sun is there,
then tilt your
panel here and then
angle it towards the
sun kind of like that.
Does that make sense?
Like the sun is there.
AUDIENCE: For a couple of hours.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Just pull it out.
PROFESSOR: You might want
to move the battery out
of the way, too because I
think it might be shading.
AUDIENCE: We're going to use
it for an angle really quick.
PROFESSOR: Makes sense.
AUDIENCE: Ready?
Yes, we're good.
19.5.
Didn't you move it?
I did move it.
The [INAUDIBLE] changed.
OK.
And so now we flip it
90 degrees and then do
the exact same thing.
That's what I was
trying to figure out.
If they're going to go metric.
You say it's 95?
PROFESSOR: This lab
is just for fun.
So I gave people the option of
either making something cool
if you're feeling
creative, or just doing
each operation with
no intent other
than learning the operation if
you're not feeling creative.
It's up to you.
So some people may
really cool stuff
and some people just had fun.
And anything is fine today.
So we're going to go
through a bunch of things.
So one, is drilling
holes in sheet metal.
And you'll also want
to cut the pvc pipe.
And you could cut
this on the band saw,
but it's probably going
to be a little uneven.
And this is actually faster
and really successful.
So what you do with
this PVC cutter, is just
open it all the way up, and then
you just keep on ratcheting.
And you fairly
quickly, cut a ring.
Very handy.
You couldn't use that tool
on metal, unfortunately.
So we have this tool
for cutting pipe.
This is the sharp bit.
And these are just bearings
that allow the pipe to spin
around and around.
So what you do is,
you open it up.
You load the copper
in, tighten it.
And then you spin it
around a few times.
You tighten it,
spin, tighten, spin.
The more times you
tighten and spin,
the cleaner edge you'll get.
If you really just use a lot
of force, of course it'll work,
but it'll be ugly.
So this is copper,
which is expensive
and we don't have
that much, so this
is the one area where you need
to just cut a little ring.
Don't cut half for yourself.
We also are going to cut rebar.
So the hacksaw is right here.
For cutting rebar
while you could just
hold the rebar in one hand, and
use the hacksaw in the other.
It's going to be really
miserable and near
impossible to do successfully.
So we have a vise.
So you can load the
rebar in and then cut.
And then when sparks fly,
give it a half a second,
then let go.
Yep.
So you--
AUDIENCE: Held it too long.
PROFESSOR: Held it too long.
And you can tell
by the diameter.
AUDIENCE: Maybe with a
bigger pipe, it'll be easier.
PROFESSOR: That helps
but the radius is wrong.